Rob I know that you have a very serious
story about a pop star his life fell
completely apart a shocking story about
Aaron Carter yeah Nancy you remember
Aaron this guy was huge back in a day
he sold millions of Records and we all
watched Aaron on Dancing with the Stars
but a massive drug addiction ruined
everything his love life his career and
he told me just how it all went downhill
so fast when I was doing Dancing with
the Stars I you know developing the
addiction to the next stage fright
actually I develop stage fright during
the show so here's Erin story it all
started in 2009 he went on dancing to
try to restart his career instead
anxiety fueled his addiction so I'm just
getting heavier and heavier and heavy
into these antics and Leslie my sister
you know she was heavy into it as well
but an opportunity happened where I
could save my life
Leslie never was presented that
opportunity I had a chance second chance
to live and you know she died from an
overdose in my father's bed Leslie was
just 25 when she died two years ago
Erin had already been to rehab how much
Nanak's were you doing um at the height
I was taking a seven two milligrams an X
bar so that means 14 milligrams a day
that is three times the average dose an
amount that would knock most people out
at what point did you you know that you
had a problem and had a stop I never
really did someone step in it I mean my
mother stepped in so her and my brother
teamed up and they got me to the Betty
Ford Center are you clean now yes
but drugs wasn't the only thing Erin was
dealing with behind the scenes of
dancing he was millions of dollars in
debt that stems from from the years when
I was like 13 14 15 I turned 18 years
old I got hit
with 2.2 million dollars of stuff that I
owe the people serving me lawsuits while
I was on the dance floor no people
didn't always know about that kind of
stuff
you were being I was being served
lawsuits while I was doing the
interviews on the dance floor
after Dancing with the Stars and then
right in front of my partner and right
in front of the interviewers and during
the show yeah and it was like so
embarrassing so what went wrong
[Music]
we know Aaron best as the pop star who
sang I want candy he made millions off
platinum-selling albums like Aaron
Carter and Aaron's party but all that
cash was mismanaged by his first manager
last year at just 25 years old he owed
more than two million dollars and filed
for bankruptcy so he went through the
bankruptcy paperwork it's public record
and lists the stuff that you still own
61 inch flat-screen TV cell phone and
units that I watch am I still wearing it
you say watch good because you got here
on time we appreciate that yeah that
says here total personal property eight
thousand two hundred and thirty-two
dollars and sixteen cents over a decade
has passed and c2 times fellow teen star
Hilary Duff and Lindsay Lohan Hilary
recently split with her husband Mike
Comrie and aren't officially back
together even though they were spotted
together at Coachella Aaron told me he
wants Hillary back you know you recently
created a bit of a stir on the internet
with a couple of tweets I want to read
them for you one is quote don't be that
stupid that loses the love of your life
forever like me and also quote I'll
spend the rest of my life trying to
better myself to get back to her I don't
care what any of you think Annie was in
capsule any regrets to sending these
tweets I don't know as Hillary responded
no not yet are you still love Hillary
I'm going to do everything in my power
to fix those relationships in my life
just like I want to fix the relationship
I had with love of my life I'm not gonna
give up on Hillary Erin's back in the
studio laying down a new album and he
invited et to his Nashville session
where he started to dream all over again
is it like getting on a bike or is there
you know a little bit of rust to shake
off it's a little more complicated than
that because it's like what did I have
to do to get people like believing in me
again